the field has changed as different
perspectives have have come in and
certainly a female perspective is very
very useful
I actually don't think people have made
the argument that that maybe because the
field is sexist and but I don't think
that is that I think that it is truly
truly an example of your your personal
biases you know like I I am personally
biased in how I ask my questions but if
but if I'm in this field and then there
are there are men who are asking they're
personally biased questions of the field
then together we will come up with
something that's going to give us a more
complete answer same thing as you know
I'm also latina right and so as a
minority I also have a different way of
looking at things that you know other
people may not have like for example you
know the fact that I am I am really
outgoing and I'm not shy talking about
sex and you know copulation and things
like that somebody who comes from a
different culture may find that you know
a lot more difficult to do and so I can
come in and I can feel that gap right
and that's the beauty of having diverse
perspectives in science is that
everybody comes we all have them our
personal biases but if we give room to
enough people with those different ideas
and those different backgrounds and
overall science is going to be better
and so that's that's really the cool
part of the story I think